today we're playing ping pong with a
leaf blower teaming up with ammo
paddlehead and more let's get into it
okay
it's got some power to it
it works perfectly
you can actually attack with it oh snap
you can sabotage air little shots it's
surprisingly good I want to see her
serve
the one where you like inserted inside
you can pick up the balls with the leaf
blower
the nice rally you have there
[Applause]
squash a fun toy remember to leave new
ideas in the comments below next
challenge is four trick shots behind the
back between the legs
360 Around the Net but to make it harder
they all have to be in the same rally
okay let's do it
yes
[Music]
roller
okay miss me let's do it
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
ready yes
[Applause]
yeah
there we go
yes
nice
they turn these around I think it's
pretty steady like still
got it this is like the third layer
maybe yeah
okay you made it easy for me as well now
it's difficult
Hmm got it this is impressive
no no you have to hit it with the pink
puncture
[Applause]
the upper one we're back in game
it wasn't the one we were going for
oh five complete layers yeah
[Applause]
yeah it's I'm getting a new nickname
again you're such a paddlehead and now
we're gonna do it I want to see how I
look I don't think you want to
you look like a four-year-old everyone's
gonna break his nose in this one
do a serve oh ml blocking head what uh
racket do you recommend for other
paddleheads the Sensei racket it's very
good for paddleheads
[Music]
we're gonna have a massive battle on my
forehead after this you already do
[Music]
the best double teams out there
next up we have six different mini games
let's see who will win the most and it's
not even enough that you get it in the
tube it has to go into the cup as well
like it barely fits the ball inside I'm
pretty sure this is going to take like
three hours everybody was close there oh
I was sure that's in maybe it's better
if I don't even see the target what is
going on behind me
oh
yeah now we know it's possible to get it
in
okay Arthur gets the first one the next
challenge is to serve three cups of the
table
there is a lot of branding like this is
a meal I have the longest way to run
like what's this
oh one more
ah thank you emu
I got it all right well D sir D served
okay third challenge bounce the ball
through all six tables and knock the cup
of the table only once on each table
only once
[Applause]
bit too many bounces on the last one
if you do that again you win the
challenge okay
[Music]
I think it was
nice
nice that was really hard
next challenge you have to shoot the
ball so that it stays on the table it
can't fall off the table
let's go
hey Mill your turn it's not gonna it's
falling off
oh yes huh
oh okay
it was going on what did it hit that's
it oh so goes into the lead two one one
situation one two three four five six
and into the cup
easy
[Music]
[Applause]
can I don't know what the cup we have to
adjust your shots okay I will you can't
move that's that's much better that's
not liking the new cup setup
[Music]
did you want to move the cup a bit again
no it's it's very good now oh this is
how you do it you pick up a pro Infinity
Bowl which by the way are back in stock
on our store and roll it into the cup
oh there we have it
you're too cheater
what do you even call this like how do
you explain this just get the ball
inside the cup you have to get at least
20 bounces
oh God
oh
congrats congrats he won it
winner of the pongfinity cup
I feel like I want to keep doing this
let's make a ping pong Orchestra
yeah that's more like it comment below
what minigames we should do in the next
one and guys that's the sound of kung
fuency balls getting back into stock on
our store and Central